the interview is directed by Evan
Goldberg and Seth Rogen and star Seth
Rogen and James Franco and has the
controversial plot of two people who are
the producers and the host of a
interview show that are asked to come
interview Kim Jong because he's such a
big fan of this show the CIA goes hey
here's an opportunity to assassinate
this guy let's do it and from then on
and we've had an endless string of
unnecessary controversy surrounding a
comedy movie with Seth Rogen come on but
I'm gonna push all that aside because
I'm here to talk about the movie I'm not
gonna think about the controversy I'm
not gonna let the hype affect me I'm
gonna approach this film as if I had
never even heard of it and it was just a
film that came on and I watched it right
off the bat the best thing about this
movie is the chemistry between Seth
Rogen and James Franco these guys play
off each other marvelously particularly
James Franco who knocks it out of the
park in this movie this might be the
funniest I've ever seen him in a movie
where he just plays an idiot because
he's always kind of the silly man - Seth
Rogen straight man like in pineapple
Express and this movie it's definitely
the same Robbins the serious one and
Franco's the idiotic one and it just
works Franco is brilliant in this movie
he is just throwing out comedy gold
almost every second at least for the
first 30 minutes for the first 30
minutes I thought this is one of the
funniest movies I've seen all year then
in the middle portion it gets a little
bit bogged down by CIA espionage and spy
stuff that isn't quite as funny and is
not really as entertaining as I think
they wanted it to be but towards the
third act it definitely picks up and
becomes a lot more funny again but there
is a weighted down second act in this
movie that I didn't find terribly funny
it did have some good jokes it did have
some funny parts but for the most part
the first and the third act by far shine
as the best parts of this movie the
writing is very clever although
admittedly very sophomoric but it works
because you just recognize that they're
just going for it they're just throwing
themselves at the mercy of the audience
this movie isn't an assault on one
particular country because this movie
definitely goes after the u.s. quite a
bit particularly the satire elements
towards the media this movie has quite a
bit to say about what makes news
headlines nowadays it actually has a lot
of cool statements about that the
opening few scenes featuring
celebrity cameos really back that up
because they have like these headlines
that are just you know crazy but it's a
kind of stuff you see like you're
scrolling through the news and oh my
gosh this famous person walked out of
their door I mean just today I was on
Facebook and it was like Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie allow their son to choose
his name that's news
really and the interview definitely has
a huge impact and it's just like totally
assaulting the media and that's honestly
one of the biggest things this movie
attacks and that's one of the smartest
aspects of this movie the way it pokes
fun at stuff the United States does
that's dumb so Rogan and Franco are
fantastic together the comedy is
definitely there for a large portion of
the movie but it is kind of bogged down
by a sort of middling second act that
kind of meanders for a while that
doesn't really know what it is at first
and then it kind of regains its footing
in the third act I also think it's a
movie that's shrouded by completely
unnecessary controversy and it's cool
that we're getting to see it you know
it's available on VOD right now on
YouTube and Google Play and tomorrow
it's going to be opening nationwide in
select theaters very few select theaters
so it's going to be out there I'm going
to give the interview a B I do think
it's funny it's not as funny as it could
be there are moments where it drags a
little bit but overall I think the
chemistry between Franco and Rogen and
particularly Franco's awesome comedic
performance in this movie save the whole
thing so guys what are your thoughts on
this whole thing let me know below and
as always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck Munoz